good morning John so I've been told
three times in the last week by creative
people running cool businesses that they
really respect my business skills and to
that I just would like to say the list
of my screw-ups is a mile long and full
of cream I'm not saying that I'm not
interested in it haven't worked hard
there are reasons why I'm fairly good at
this a big one is that I do like solving
problems I like getting a good feel for
them and finding different ways to
attack them and worrying about them I
find this to be fun creative work that's
actually kind of similar to plotting a
novel - I see it as good employing
people treating them fairly creating
value for the world finding ways for
that value to sustain itself reap my dad
has run businesses and whenever I have a
problem I can call him and he helps me
it's extremely valuable I could go on
for I've gotten very lucky with hiring
and all those things have helped and I'm
happy to take some credit where it's due
but ultimately I have a secret and it
will be absolutely no help when I tell
you about it every business I have
launched that has succeeded has been
launched with the support of a really
wonderful online community honestly this
is part of why dftba now gives all of
John and my profit to the maternal
center of excellence in Sierra Leone
where the Florida's channel revenue has
always been split between charity and
supporting smaller educational video
channels and I look at this honestly and
objectively and I think about where the
value came from it always feels to me
like a lot of the value came from the
employees and this community and less
from me because I'm just one person
right there are times when I have
pounded myself into the ground to get
things done I've had a lot of bad weeks
in my life in running a business it's
important to understand where your value
comes from it's important to understand
your strengths and this community has
always been at the top of the list of
our string and that's not just like
marketing to you it's finding people who
can tell us how to do things finding
people to hire getting immediate product
feedback like there's a reason I keep
talking about soda syrups I'm trying to
get you to tell me how you feel about
soda sir and basically no one has this
asset now other people have similar
assets but not like nerdfighteria right
not this good so if it hesitant to give
advice when my biggest asset is
something that I don't
to share but I would like for us to
build a business
now here's that's gonna work if you are
a business person and you think you
could help this idea by providing
mentorship or helping us pick business
ideas that are submitted to us I've
created a form in the description and
it's next to the words I can help if you
think you have expertise that will be
valuable on a small board of people
making decisions in providing mentorship
fill that out second if you are an
entrepreneur if you have a product or a
service that you are excited about that
you've started to grow but you need a
push I've got a form for you as well
it's called I need help now in general
we're looking for stuff that's beyond
the idea stage and then it actually has
a product or service or business
developed a little bit can fill this out
with just an idea but it's better be a
banger basically but here's the sticky
bit I'm gonna give this business $50,000
but if the business is able to become
successful over the next three years we
want to get that $50,000 back to promote
maternal health in Sierra Leone and
every year when you do your profit
distributions 10% of after-tax income
should also go to support that effort if
that sounds good to you and you've got
an idea that can grow but need some
mentorship and some support from an
amazing audience of cool people who want
to support good thing the forum is down
in the description John I think
everybody has the ability to be a
business owner now not everybody has the
inclination but even if you don't I
think everyone should watch the crash
course business entrepreneurship
learning playlist it's a 17 episode
series hosted by Anna Akana that goes
over the basics of starting your own
business and also of business in general
link to that playlist is here and in the
description and those forms that I was
telling you about are down there as well
John I'll see you on Tuesday